here is kawhi leonard paul george and
beverly the five for the clippers good
defense inside by davis pass break and
lebron the other way
whoa we put it down hard
caldwell pope but the look ahead here by
schroeder and lebron james mello picked
up by george to teammates in oklahoma
city
jordan doesn't buy the pump think it
doesn't matter mello knocks it in he has
been a spark plug off the bench
[Applause]
lebron gives it away sterling brown and
that is blocked by anthony davis on the
other end
i mean i'm all for trying
oh he's right there catch us
[Music]
oh
westbrook got there
because it looked like it was going to
be a clean look for levert who played
well
home court
in that play-in situation
[Music]
they moved to ninth indiana drops to ten
on a night that russell westbrook makes
history
tying oscar robertson
and westbrook gets his second block of
the night
up and down pace they go derek jones jr
oh denied by lebron james tucker getting
around the defense and finishing and
then on defense lebron
making that effort you have to love that
lillard doubled picked up the dribble
now down to two the skip pass to carmelo
good hustle by looney made it anyway
blazers play beat the clock did a good
job of recognizing that the laker bigs
were not in position to contest the shot
a d the spin in the slam anthony davis
working it inside
anthony davis quit showing off 35 for bl
2 point game matthews with the steal
here's westbrook for three he hits it
where'd you jump by one
wow unbelievable
and this was not like right here look at
garrison here garrison matthews
get that
to russell westbrook put a three i mean
did that just happen
[Applause]
now you got to make them pay for the the
turnover here
lebron will oh my god oh logo ball he's
got it
did they say wesley touched that on the
shot look at this logo three by lebron
boy and it doesn't look like he does
anything extra to deliver it a lot of
players have to do it
young defends mello three to shoot mello
step back trey
gets it to roll in so portland
a season high
eight threes
i mean
if you miss you want to leave time to be
able to commit a foul and lengthen the
game schroeder going all the way dishes
a d
throws it down to tyler
no whistle though schroeder sets it up
drives makes plumley commit spots
anthony davis and
anthony davis glides in for the flush
turnover off the inbounds
and now anthony cooper gets it taken
away westbrook for the big duck
lebron james
closing in on a triple double kuzma
hanks can't finish but lebron over the
top 36 year old
how many games does this guy play
yeah you know there's going to be some
contact it just doesn't matter he rises
above the
defender and puts it back with the
emphatic jam
and you you see on the video
four players in double figures in this
first half five to shoot dame getting
through the defense loses the handle
mellow there to get it off the glass
they've got to get a little bit more
ball and body movement
jd
what a dish from schroeder
and he threw that one down with
authority
notices the real the roll man right
there and
hands it off and anthony davis does the
rash flushes it we've got a two-point
king's lead
seconds to go
westbrook the hesitation oh
the monster jammed by russell westbrook
and the foul
oh my gosh i mean
dip him in holy water
oh
man
and he wanted all the action afterwards
i mean look at that
oh [ __ ] 18 years professionally at the
highest level
we mentioned that what a pass right
martin tucker what a pass he is houdini
in stride bull bull was in
i mean taylon horton tucker
in stride with the easy finish
on point simmons stays with him
shot clock down to three here's carmelo
anthony got to put up a tough one so oh
keep it going carmelo anthony cannot
miss right now
i mean think about this one b.a
shot clock running down desperation shot
he uses the glass
talking about going in your bag
[Applause]
it's going to be jokic
he looked to give it back to rivers now
dribbles it out the pazzo from downtown
davis miraculously with a close-out that
never seemed to end this is just
ridiculous defensively
over the last two years as the closest
offender that guy is number two in the
league there's a reason why
six foot ten long athletic and
unbelievable instincts look at the
ground covered the stretch out
a live update steph curry's got 25 in
the game for golden state against boston
the lob to westbrook oh wow
[Applause]
i mean great back screen play out of the
timeout look at the hang time
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that string by lopez right there
probably got away with illegal but it
freed up
montrez shot and game or just about sync
for the tie
lebron ties it at 105.
well now a good game where the lakers
are going into o
t
second time in a row against the thunder
stevens on an island defending dame
dam gets to his left flips it outside
carmelo anthony pump fake
and a three before the buzzer for
carmelo anthony
ball side 73.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
which is way too much a d going for more
nasty
four
and then this backwards alley-oop dunk
and a foul by devin booker
what else does this man have up his
sleeve today
good defense by beal kept alive but
westbrook rips the rebound down
leaves it for gafford for the big dunk
he just knows
where to run to being in the right place
at the right time
and finishing
schroeder who's had a quiet night
himself two points one of four from the
floor
james look out
the tomahawk throw down
from lebron james
watch this and look just throws a needle
between two defenders and puts a little
extra on it
man
and the laker bench look at that they're
they're having so much fun
that we have on the other side hand on
the hip or on the back
i'm sure eight would like to have that
over again here's lebron and crowder was
right there for him he knew it was
coming
another laker turnover booker running
the floor a little sidestep oh denied
off the glass
well you don't give up on the play i
mean it's this is you know game three
levert to answer no westbrook up ahead
beale oh wow
what a play
russ
throwing that on the money but i like
what brad did he turned that into a
nicole jokic
nails it
james drives down a lane goes up and
throws it down
how does that happen
a dunk down the other end you know what
that is and then lebron split the double
team and then just takes off you pointed
out
he was a big part of the blazers offense
being able to take advantage of some
mismatches yeah
and then playing point as mello is going
to have a chance
for four
hits the three through contact
foul
and abdia it's the subtle shots that
it's not a shot with a compliment i was
asking if he did okay funny man i've had
one since grandma school that's for sure
davis knocks down the three-pointer
minute left
first half
there's lead on the drive and put home
by westbrook remaining in the first half
foul those on alex
and westbrook
just
beautiful anticipation
tip tip dunk right there goes up with
authority and smacks his teammate for
good measure in the head
at the strike 92 free throw shooter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's 36
and he looks like he's on that cover of
si that you were showing a couple
minutes ago reggie
but hold on look at kevin durant on the
brooklyn bench
for murray to get started once you see
the ball go through the
through the rim
hurry up missed six consecutive field
goal attempts here's mello and he scores
up and over zeke naji
able to rattle one home only to be
answered by carmelo jim
carmello again
i need to shoot he'll back it up and
charge again a.d
[Music]
anthony davis
robin lopez
[Music]
russell with lopez over embiid and
russell westbrook on the follow his end
of the bargain hasn't he oh yeah he's
getting it done as we see rush right
here get it done catching that lob but
bradley bill has 17 points
morris puts it in lebron james now
westbrook
guarding lebron westbrook trying to stay
with him and lebron james is found and
count the basket switches on to lebron
james and fouls him here
and lebron able to score man oh man
huge i don't like i don't like that
switch for washington
mello
gets the catch from lillard under four
to shoot
mello baseline jumper oh that was needed
for portland
russia mello catches there goes the
coaches
from minnesota they're standing up
trying to tell him come dump do not let
this man
spurs under three minutes
[Applause]
how clean is that
westbrook for the lead hachimaran
what a way to get your first basket of
the night
how about this put back here by russell
westbrook
been struggling from the field
but doesn't get none easier than that
finds jones oh good pass to hood
kuzma goes by him hood can't knock down
the three it's been a struggle for hook
career low and scoring and three-point
shooting great look down for it and it
spins home for montrez harrell to pull
la within four
[Applause]
and what you're not seeing here from
this pass and great just right straight
up great passing great finish but prior
to this there was a sixth place scramble
here's mellow with 13 points trying to
go one on one against hart shot clock
winding down mellow quick little step
back here that's a luxury when right now
time is your friend trying to jump the
game up on the defensive end i think
this man man-to-man defensive kind of a
match-up
westbrook's got
152 now
oscar's record at 181
and there's westbrook hammers one home
does a pull-up on the rim
and one for russell westbrook an
explosive right there just
a change of direction exploding to the
rim like the young russell restaurant
did a little chin up too for good
measure
[Applause]
lakers have time here's james with four
lebron with two lets it fly and heads at
the buzzer 73 first half points a season
high for the lakers and lebron james
just taking his time he knows he has
plenty of time and just pulls up from
deep knocks it down just adding three
more points to this already monstrous
lead by the los angeles lakers
[Applause]
mellow will go at cleva
mello will try the three at the horde
got it
carmelo anthony
three to the top get him back to three
that he felt he just gave up on the
other end huge shot to close a quarter
lasers trail by five fourth quarter
coming your way
got 21 points to lead both teams hasn't
had a shot here in the third quarter yet
might get one here
better get one here it will be a
violation two with one the turn he's
perfect still
shot clock our carl's camp to show
shot goes up shot goes down and
christian woods says nothing i can do
with this guy just just nothing i can do
on the decupo
shot clock to four he needs help
somehow got it off
i don't know maybe you switch pivot foot
left foot kick it out wide open three
they don't get it rebound lebron long
lead for kuzma got it touchdown pass
more bench points tonight for the lakers
one point lead time now to check in with
the accident his time with the clippers
averaging
slightly above 20 points per game
throughout
those years and then it was a 20 point
per game score with the pistons
[Music]
melo always sees that they spread it out
from lebron james
looney on him kicks it to davis lay
clock again davis goes lost the handle
gets it back oh and a power jam
on a player not being denied right here
doesn't settle for the three
nice job by the warriors initially but
gets the ball back in a.d with the
finish
just tries to take off the rim here
a 25 point lead for the wizards five
seconds to go westbrook
will pull up for the jumper got it
you know lakers in a string of three
straight games seeing the top three
picks in the draft
james all the way reverse slayer of the
circus shot for lebron get that play
where lebron had it they had him and
then both defenders leave him then he
makes the
up and up
that's though hang on to a one-point
lead
lillard trying to go with claxton steps
through mello has to get it up before
the horn what a fine by lillard yes once
again
get into the
a.d trying to spin he's got young right
on him a d not there montrez has got it
montrez with four seconds to a d and
there it is so the lakers avoid their
worst quarter of the year on a good
offensive rebound by montreal and he's
showing that he can rebound the ball
he's not just sitting out casting shots
make a miss he's doing other things to
impact the game
westbrook has to put the three up with
the shot clock winding down he hits the
three teams first
here's russell westbrook
and he was
last break advantage so far in this game
14-9 layman oh blocked by james
lebron james was that a blocker did he
hit the front of the rim
[Applause]
cook will clean things up
stork is the one to keep that play alive
for the pistons oh another quick pass
mellow once again in the deep end able
to get it look at this wrestling match
they're jostling the cutting out of
caruso blocked by allen taken by a.d and
he scores did they give them a new 24 or
what
westbrook for three again hits it
russell westbrook has three of the four
threes
for the wizards tonight here they come
it's one on four so graham did the smart
thing
but the quickness now rolls here blocked
by james as he came over to block it
from rozier you might beat me with the
first step but you better be able to
finish up here i come there it goes
and that's on about one and a half
threes attempted per game
here's mello shot clock winding down has
to get it up fades away over joseph and
carmelo anthony dialed in tonight
versatility as a scorer
this is the last thing that they want to
see
[Music]
tremendous find a tremendous fit
five on the shot clock ties now guarding
lebron james schroeder fakes kicks it
out davis is left open as the shot clock
except it plays right into your
wheelhouse
when you're left-handed two seconds
westbrook's three got it at the buzzer
what a first quarter in front of the
fans for the first time this season you
know there's the yardstick that i like
to use for the lakers when kcp is
involved in active offensively this
laker team can be very tough schroeder
the love throw it down king
15 11. what a play
by lebron james and that forces a
timeout with the lakers up by four
[Applause]
three seconds left for the blaze here's
mellow the crossover trying to get into
the two double clutch and it's good
carmelo anthony that's when you go ahead
let her roll out pull it back
dribble into the mid-range
huge bucket for carmelo anthony doubling
lebron james
a lot davis against tice nearly took it
away now steps back floats it up and
puts it in as the shot clock expires
[Applause]
here's westbrook with four
pull-up jumper is good for russ with
five tenths of a second left
so the wizards put up 61 points
so lebron and the lakers looking for win
number 42
on the air and 21 on the road all behind
the back to caruso how do you do really
pretty look at him surveying it
this time nerk is trying to fight
through two bodies nurkich
chases down the loose rock under four to
shoot melo rises up nothing but net
anthony davis
and defending
is the big man jokic with the shot clock
down to two
and a d will drain it
you can't do that with davis right there
because that's an easy pass off a
three-point shot here's a steal by
westbrook and westbrook will throw it
down
hey
there it is
just getting up getting deflections
there's a steal about russ these guys
can't catch up with him that's all she
wrote
by two
the captivating play by lebron james
hammers it home for the lakers
here is simon's
clock winding down mellow
under three to shoot mello the step back
jumper everything falling for the
blazers and they complete 27 points 10
rebounds ninth double-double of the
season for james
the durability
filling oh and what a pass and flying
and coming out of the rafters was
anthony davis for two all night denver
is below 40 percent at 39.8 what another
beautiful pass well timed by james that
passing of james
he's got a lot of attributes that's
about as good fakes the screen now it's
westbrook against sabonis former
teammates in okc
shot clock to four
westbrook puts up the jumper got it
wizards retake the lead with one second
to go
this has become personal between these
two
cleared out lebron wants crowder shot
clock to seven spins off of him lebron
hangs the reverse is good and look at
the laker bench
[Applause]
nurkic over to mello four to shoot mello
working on forest fading away and he has
done that to so many players in this
league i mean he was wide open and with
the clock winding down he had every
right to take that shot but knew that
carmelo has enough time
and except for that awful second quarter
they played pretty well tonight davis
a
d
doing it
well that is string love it music love
it kathy davis back to his old ways
it has been highly entertaining on this
saturday night
deal
[Music]
westbrook to give washington the lead
[Applause]
it's considered i mean i mean he gets it
off i don't think there's any question
he gets
craig the former nugget who was acquired
from the bucks early this season
mclemore three-pointers good
about that pass from lebron
well james got hung up in the air
and made
something great out of nothing ben
mclemore sticks to three
32-30 end of the first quarter here's
anthony again oh he got another one
earned 12 points five minutes you think
he's happy to be there
oh
yes sir
[Music]
[Applause]
davis looking to answer does rattling
home on the triple
and then anthony davis the response
no fouls to give for atlanta
what should be the final possession of
the first half westbrook for three
knocks it down russell westbrook his
fourth three-pointer and the wizards
retake the lead
that's three points made up off of a
call that should have been made
amen oh james amen on that but spinning
on the slam
now the lakers go up by nine
playing well great left to right spin by
james and his sprint down the court was
even better
a mouth a gate
and right now the blazers just looked
stunned
team with all kinds of playoff
experience can they respond anthony has
to fire and hits
big shot for the blazers
this anthony three was actually
portland's first basket of the quarter